joining us just a delight seeing him and
one of my favorite television shows cuz
it's always a little light heaven um my
fellow native New Yorker on this program
he's Frank Grillo back here on the show
and he's on billions and his character
finally made it on air this week and I
can't wait to see where this goes how
are you Frank well we took up we took a
wager here cuz we know that you were
supposed to be on 20 minutes ago and
we'll take you anytime we can get you
that you were doing ab work that's what
I was running late at the my boxing
coach came lady C and DC so I was yeah
you know it's kind of funny because
there's a conversation about pizza and
Jordan ate a pizza and all that stuff
and we saw you know that that was his
flu game stuff and we saw this past week
that you and axe Bobby Axelrod kind of
made a deal together over pizza and it's
funny i watch that show with my wife
Suzy and she's you know she said to me
Frank as you were eating the peaches I
bet that's the only pizza frank grillo
is eaten in the last 20 years
she said yes Peter
yes sir it was paleo pizza I made them
get me they weren't happy about it they
weren't happy Emmanuel aesthetically
aesthetically doesn't look like pizza
but we made it work so are you saying
are you that high-maintenance about your
diet that you told you told me makers of
billions you told complement and Levine
and the rest of them I need honey almond
crusted pizza to eat here yes you know I
don't want to risk getting a tummy ache
while I'm shooting possibly gasps
possibly so you're doing it not just for
your body but for others around you
you're doing it because you're a good
you're a good you're you're an ensemble
actor that's what you're saying I I'm
not and I'm gonna fire my agent from
putting on TV
it's a great show man I'm excited I'm
excited to see where this goes
before the whole world collapsed and I'm
right and it really fun it's a cool
little role something different for me
it's you know I didn't kill anybody or
have a love interest
eventually oh never nobody me go near
women so yeah I'm assuming this is
though is the love interest a longtime
character on the show Frank yes is it is
it is it is it Wendy Rhodes Frank
because that would be quite a crossing
of the streams I don't watch the program
and I hate talking about acting but I
got out and you know this guy who's got
he can't be bought he can't be bought
right you know there's bad federal thing
that anybody has everybody has a price
and it kind of goes down a path that
looks obvious and then right those two
guys that write that show switched it up
can you paint in real life Frankie play
in a compliment I I do paint okay and I
have a painting that I did that's
hanging up in my my living room I live
in Venice now by myself okay that's a
whole other story we won't get into
right and I've been paid with my boy -
okay I got a bunch of canvases around
the house we always kind of we screw
around depending can i Commission you
for to paint something Frank I'm
available for gardening for anything
because I think seems to have gone away
well here's the thing Frank it's cuz you
know just like Bobby Axelrod I can help
name your price Chris can you hold up
the photograph that I'd like Frank sure
can
yeah it's it's of me running behind my
dog on the beach in the surf Frank
[Laughter]
no I know it's your favorite Frank so
would you could you paint this for me on
commission
what do you think could I ever and by
the way for you buddy it's family and
friends rate alright yeah Frank I know
you love it so much you talked about it
every single time you've been in here
and I know I think your favorite part
about it um is my running style I think
you're running so as we in the sports
world like to call your gate so I'm by
the way I'm deadly serious have you
paint this would you like that you know
what's your interpretation I'm I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not really you know
in any way shape or form demanding I
want you know you're the artist it's
your vision it's your eye and I just
want to make sure that you're just you
know eating paleo pizza before you do it
so I can get the best around my house
it's my job in the mirror I'm wearing
army fatigue patterns almost bikini like
underwear I don't know I mean seriously
I don't know if you know again it's it's
up to you it's in the eye of the
beholder okay are you are you shirtless
to Frank I mean is it really that's all
you are absolutely just in my skivvies
all right
you let your let you let you let your
freak flag front fly in any way you want
frank grillo that's the way you know
we're tight like that I guess
Oh God so have you watched any of this
last night stuff or no you watch this
whole thing man I am obsessed obsessed
upset you can't you can't create a
better story than that right I know and
just you know I'm so I'm so I'm so
disgusted
I'm so mad you know how I felt about
Brady's we watched Jordan and those guys
you're like wow am I even a man am i a
man well I think you just told us where
you're walking around the house I think
you are Frank oh man I think you
answered that question quite frankly but
no I don't know if you watched it the
same way I did which is to see like the
trivia answer the guy who Jordan
eliminated the most Patrick Ewing the
number of times that he stood in the
Knicks way it was I just it just
rekindled all my anger and
disappointment no you know I think come
on Patrick Ewing one of the greatest
players that has no rent from the next I
great
of course right I mean you could even
save not from the Knicks just period but
everybody he got everybody Jordan got
everybody you know Karl Malone cried he
got everybody I didn't you know again
you project he's been gone for a minute
right how spectacular and special he was
really do you go to the garden those
words Frank were you in the garden
Allah's ears when you're watching right
I know yeah so yeah I've been watching
that I that's what I've been doing the
last few Sundays is watching that and
then and then going for billions as soon
as it's over oh I love that show Frank
I'm so excited to see where you what
you're gonna do in that show and what
you know where it's gonna all go what do
you think of the return of UFC
you know did you watch it did you watch
Tony Ferguson capito I saw it I didn't
watch it live but I did subsequently see
that somebody had a baseball bat and
we're hitting a pig it was like pound
the crackle of the punches were more
interesting but but you know listen it's
better than having nothing on television
you know I know
he was supposed to fight khabib whose
dad apparently is really in bad way with
kovat plus so yeah I know he was
supposed to fight Kabir and I guess
that's a good fight that we're gonna see
yeah
so you were locked in know that that
happens now I don't know that it's that
good of a fight anymore because you know
the machine has been taken off of
Ferguson so you know I I don't think
Ferguson comes back to think fighter
I really don't who's the best what's the
best fighter do you think in UFC what do
you got for me Frank the one guy the one
that you would correct the one who you
would pay frank grillo dollars to put
down on any sort of pay-per-view that
you say I will watch this person fight
doesn't matter weight class doesn't
matter who who was that fighter you know
I have to tell you before this fight
it was Ferguson huh yeah it was Ferguson
I really wanted to see him fight too
deep and because kebede you know albeit
he has a good chin he doesn't have the
greatest stand-up game and Ferguson was
just it's just so well-rounded and and
doesn't gasp I mean spectacular output
so for all the other reasons right
doesn't matter that he gets beat he's
just very important to the sport no
doubt about it all right Frank yep
can't wait to see more of you on
billions again that's Showtime Sunday
nights 9:00 Eastern Time very much
looking forward to that I am going to
photograph this this photograph and I
really want you to I want you to
Commission it and however you want to
paint it we'll put it up here in the
Rich Eisen show studio and I say this
with the ultimate of respect and love
put some clothes on Willie please take
care of yourself Frank all right yeah
Sammy it's Frank Grillo the one and only
put something on Frank hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here